frank rosin hat ein restaurant
eineinhalb stunden von ihr entfernt wir
sind hingefahren und haben dort gegessen
das restaurant hat zwei michelin sterne
und frank rosin steht einfach für gutes
essen wir waren sehr gespannt ob diese
hohen erwartungen erfüllt werden konnten
aber seht selbst wir sind jetzt also
angekommen leute und ich sage so viel
ich blicke gerade auch das restaurant
ich muss sagen es sieht sehr gesagt man
sehr sehr visum gast ja so ist die k
laus irgendwie ein bisschen rustikal
aber ich glaube das ist auch das konzept
weil eigentlich ist das glaube ich gar
nicht super ausgefallen gelassen es
gleich nochmal alles erklären ich würde
aber sagen das ist einfach mal rein auf
jeden fall sieht man hier prosieben
restaurant frankfurt.de alles
schmackhafte von frank rosin glaube
relativ klar was für namen da steht und
mit zwei michelin-sternen muss auch
wirklich gut sein deshalb gehen wir es
mal ein
also lass dich trotzdem noch mal reden
ja
gerne gurken leben wo klingt super finde
ich würde nicht nur gurken demo nehmen
gerne ganz ernst
die
kolonne lichter
kurz gesagt was mir zu dem zeitpunkt
einfach noch nicht wie wir das gesamte
auftreten vom restaurant einordnen
sollen weil es war irgendwie sehr
klassisch gehalten aber auf der anderen
seite waren da sehr fleischige bilder an
der wand und insgesamt war es einfach
ein bisschen viel
ganz ganz anders als erwartet ich habe
die ganzen extra wieder nicht viel
angeschaut und was soll ich sagen hallo
yoko ist ganz ganzen welt aber erst mal
ein paar fragen
wurden platz gebeten
also erstmal ne
danke sieht sie aus oder ich sag mir
eigentlich schon hohe erwartungen an den
franzosen zwei sternen wir waren dem ein
sterne restaurants hat mich weggefegt
ich freue mich auf unseren kurzurlaub
von 114 recht sondern das war ja dass
das besondere daran war das ist wirklich
halten so ein urlaub waren komplett sind
auch mal festhalten dass ich habe dieses
restaurant
30 jahre ist noch nicht so lange auf dem
niveau natürlich gleich aber also
interesse und das ist schon normal
genau da nehmen wir beide das drei gang
menü und wir stellen uns dann selbst
zusammen und gibt es eine empfehlung für
das 3gs wahrscheinlich ganz nach
präferenz beraten den kann man da ist
supergut das müssen wir festhalten guck
mal eric zeigt euch gerade mal der sonne
ami von frank rosin für das ist ein
guter wein gewidmet weil sicherlich sind
auch viele leute hier die franzosen
feiern ja dann die wirkung von ihnen
quasi ist schon cool drei sachen kriegt
man immer immer gruß aus der küche top
und jetzt müssen wir beide
entscheidungen stehen aber dass wir das
gleiche nehmen
danke schön
[Musik]
hart vorgänger 3gs aus herzliche und so
was anscheinend in den rücken im
aufrichtiges am ende wirklich wird man
kennt ja nein nein
und vier gänge
hallte in der hauptstadt wir haben da
wirklich einen harten start gab das
müssen wir aus dem koffer ich habe jetzt
hier schon noch einen gewissen
superlecker das super cool ist wir sind
über suchen eine steile heiß gemacht
sind so entstellt da merken wir das ist
schon sowas ereignis und eigene gedanken
habe ich als amateur
das dankeschön dankeschön sehr hübsch
das ist fast ein bisschen dieses ding es
wird wieder eine reise heute ja aber ich
bin übels gespannt wie das jetzt
reinhören wird die b rico bäckchen
restaurant dosen fragt einmal s6
schlüsselbänder also platzes probieren 7
mehr aus wie pringles eigentlichen
schritten wie es kommt
jetzt sind wir angekommen jetzt sind wir
da wo
wir zu einem ganzen zu leisten so auch
ihre cremigkeit da war alles dabei und
das war ein bringen jetzt gedankt alles
bisher war trotz aber jetzt täglich das
war super das ist aber auch sehr bedacht
haben ja wissen ob sie schon was
abtragen nicht nur das essen wird ja bei
der sterneküche bewertet auch der
service und das ambiente
geht es besser so das ist das ist
einfach fakt dass wir da einfach mehr
gewohnt sind und dass hier da einfach
nicht so heraus sticht ich wunderschön
ich glaube so inneneinrichter würden
sich hier nicht wohlfühlt weil so zu
viele stilbrüche hier da sind und das
ist zwar scheinbar eine kleine sache
aber man erwartet einfach perfektion und
irgendwie sucht man auch und sowas fällt
dann auf und bringt an irgend ein klein
bisschen raus
für sehr ändern da sind wir jetzt schon
er jetzt ist es offiziell machst du
schweinebauch ja
ich muss aber auch wieder sagen dafür
was das ist wird wenig ausgemacht so
perfektes quadratfuss schweinebauch dann
so eine rolle in irgendeinem komplex
also noch nicht produziert ich hoffe
dass wir den schauen
damit habe ich schon mal da ist bestimmt
auch so eine kleine gedachte
überraschung oder du gehst davon aus
dass auch warmes herz ist ist es auch
wieder raus damit offen was dich
noch nie so schweiz mit 24 stunden
gedauert als das fett ist einfach nur so
ein gelee ja wirklich nur ein teleskop
alles unfassbar das ist eigentlich eine
gute ein gutes zwischenfazit und gern
ein so gutes brot ist noch nicht so gut
eine woche ist
froh dass es trug das ist wie das ohne
intensive scheiße alter
schön gesagt ich habe einen job das ist
der spaß einem sterne küchen muss die
gerichte zu verstehen aber ich kann noch
nicht sagen ob es mich mehr fläche als
düsseldorf es muss ja eigentlich mehr
wegen zwei sterne gegen ein stern und
das war der moment wo wir zum ersten mal
richtig begriffen haben was wir
eigentlich erwarten dürfen wir waren ja
in einem ein sterne restaurant in
düsseldorf vor nicht allzu langer zeit
und das haben wir jedes mal wieder als
referenz rang gut und haben festgestellt
das ist wirklich viel was sein muss um
noch besser zu sein als was manche
danken ich glaube die atmosphäre alles
funktioniert viel besser in der land ful
ist verstehst du dann kommt diese
offenheit
laut so weist das ist eigentlich die
absicht ja ich habe dass das was nicht
so sicher schließlich ist gerade ich
meine wir haben halt auch einen
dienstagabend wer geht der klassische
die gesamtbeschäftigung oder als youtube
über in deutschland mit einer fassen
millionen abonnenten
richtig hettstedter
[Musik]
natürlich
gar nicht ich bin sehr gespannt auf die
erste tour bist du der gar punkte ente
die ist einfach komplett rosa ist elfter
ich nehme zu allererst was von unserer
ente ich glaube dass du dir das wird
kraft
alles zusammen kostet das alles zusammen
lassen hat gut geschmeckt
der zoll ist ja immer auch hier werde
schauen wir haben ein ice der soße wir
haben so ein kompott und konfekt
diese steckt ihr saft knüpft direkt bei
diesen kontrollen falls ihr euch fragt
warum wir von den beiden begleiterinnen
nimmt beide keine ahnung von
sehr hübsch
[Musik]
schokolade
schokoladen höhe und dies und noch mal
gefüllt wie man sieht durch diese
glasscheibe nahm er
der nachwelt
kissen geile konsistenz oder creme darin
[Musik]
absolut gutes erstes dass er einst von
drei tagen der effekt fehlt hier habe
ich mehr erwartet wäre da gewesen wenn
wir als erstes stadt einen setzkasten
hierher gekommen dann sind wir schon
anders hingegangen natürlich muss man
sagen dass es ein wahnsinns privileg ist
dieses essen überhaupt jemals essen zu
dürfen in dieser qualität in so einem
teuren restaurant aber gerade weil es so
teuer ist muss man es auch kritisieren
dürfen und darf man auch die ganz
kleinen sachen anschauen und das haben
wir gemacht kurze reminder noch mal für
euch 99 euro für drei gänge
dann gesehen
war das sieht sehr fein raus
du weißt du es mein erster eindruck ist
wohl normal aber es braucht nicht was
schwimmt nächstes kennt weiß was ich
meine das hier wird die weiße schokolade
sein ich wäre als erstes immer kommen zu
probieren
die mainzerin kommt die super
wenn wir in kommunizierte getrocknet
orange kleinen verpacken aber ich finde
anis lavendel schmecken wie so ein
bisschen betragen das ist nicht so
also ich find's super gut aber es ist in
allen punkten ein bisschen weniger es
fühlt sich weniger an ich glaube es
fühlt sich aber auch einfach nach
weniger an weil es halt eben teurer ist
man weniger gänge hat und werden beim
letzten halt auch super show indem er
halt mitten in der küche saßen
[Musik]
du hast das heißt glasiert und das ist
neu
16 17
der cast nennen beurteilte auch über dem
baltikum jedes bisschen schwerfällig
wenn man so dass er auf der spitze von
mannstein balancieren und das finde ich
schade ist dass nicht knusprig ist aber
das ist kein kurswechsel das ist aber
sehr lecker anfassen heißt jetzt kann
ich auch gut mal nicht so cremig sondern
wir also gefrorene sagen aber die papa
will nicht verstanden vielen dank
wiedersehen hatte dass der netto cash
flow das war ein erlebnis wir sind
angekommen das war jetzt ist dunkel
dazwischen liegen fast drei stunden und
darum ist erst mal nachdenken bevor
davon sachen dürfen ja das müssen wir
erst mal sacken safe aber ab nach köln
also leute ihr seht ihr meine bewertung
ich habe mir einen tag zeit genommen mir
viele gedanken gemacht viel spaß ein
großer name und zwei sterne meine
erwartungen hätten kaum größer sein
können angekommen am restaurant rosin
musste ich gleich zweimal hingucken da
die fassade keinesfalls auffällig oder
gar extravagant ist umso gespannter war
ich ob das innenleben des restaurants er
meinen erwartungen an ein zwei sterne
restaurant entspricht doch auch im
inneren bot sich ein sehr klassisches
bild lediglich die kunstwerke an den
wänden versuchten einen stilbruch der
auf mich ein wenig unbeholfen wirkte was
uns jedoch sofort auffiel war die
freundlichkeit des personals welches
sich an einem schwach besuchten
dienstagabend wirklich sehr häufig nach
unserem wohl effekt hat so weit so
unbesonnen und zwar klar dass wir über
unseren gaumen überzeugt werden soll
nach sehr gutem brot mit butter kam dann
endlich das aufatmen ein ta cco der mit
einem bisschen verspeist war und eine
unglaubliche geschmackliche vielfalt und
raffinesse offenbar so kann es
weitergehen ging es aber nicht nicht
falsch verstehen alles was uns da wird
wurde war handwerklich einwandfrei in
punkten raffinessen und innovation
passierte aber deutlich weniger als ich
erwartet hätte vor nicht allzu langer
zeit habe ich ein junges restaurant mit
nur einem stern besucht welches alles
was ich hier kritisiere besser gemacht
hat 30 jahre restaurant rosinen sind ein
toller meilenstein aber vielleicht auch
ein guter anlass und kreative neue wege
zu gehen ich bin mir sicher dass sie
gegangen werden könnten ich habe fünf
sterne mit tendenz nach oben erwartet
und vergebe
44 hab's gesehen es ist auf jeden fall
nicht einfach gewesen das zu bewerten
und ich möchte einmal daran erinnern
dass es nicht frank rosin der da in der
küche stand und für uns gekocht hat
sondern sein team aber ich hoffe dass
unser video vielleicht ein bisschen als
konstruktive kritik gesehen werden kann
und dass ihr vor allem spaß hatte beim
zuschauen wenn ja würde ich nicht über
ein like und ein abo freuen wir sind
kurz vor einer million und wir sehen uns
im nächsten video ganz bestimmt wieder